ces images sont celles de résidents de
la ville occupée de kherson dans le sud
de l'ukraine il avance vers la place de
la liberté en même temps des militaires
russes vente à leur encontre et ouvrent
le feu
après avoir subi le siège les
bombardements kherson subi les affres de
la répression par des tirs d'armes
automatiques et de gaz lacrymogènes
rentrez chez-vous scandé tillières en
marchant vers les camions russes les
forçant à faire demi-tour
à marie open la ville refuse de
capituler malgré l'ultimatum lancé par
les russes pour
michael et sa famille la situation dans
la ville est devenue invivable
oui je sais
il a réussi à fuir la ville hier à la
faveur d'un convoi humanitaire mais son
fils de 3 ans et demi est toujours
traumatisée par ce qu'il a vu et où
mika y raconte que son fils parle
constamment d'un homme qui a perdu son
bras et sa jambe qu'il pose encore des
questions sur les bombes les temps que
les avions militaires légers the works
rails mais chez vous c'est un crime de
guerre majeure lance le chef de la
diplomatie européenne qui dénonce ce qui
se passe à marioupol
à odessa la ville se prépare au pire des
citoyens prennent les armes les
barricades sont érigées je doute que
l'armée russe sutton un
débarquement avec les barges et les
troupes depuis la mer parce que s'ils
n'ont pas des troupes qui les
soutiennent depuis depuis la terre
je pense que ça serait un massacre parce
qu'ils sont vraiment attendu que ce soit
par les militaires et par les civils et
les troupes terrestres russe n'arrive
pas à passer par micola nf3 river road
et ça on va bombarder détruire comme on
détruit toutes les autres villes
en entrevue avec des médias européens le
président céline ce qui a dit qu'il
n'acceptera pas d'ultimatum
maraude il a ajouté que d'éventuelles
compromis durant les négociations seront
soumis à référendum plus tôt il avait
appelé à des pourparlers directs avec
vladimir poutine car il faut aussi
décider de l'avenir du dombass où il ya
rina 26 ans militaire du corps des
marines ukrainien défend les villages
contre l'assaillant elle nous parle
depuis le champ de bataille
[Musique]
durant l'entrevue ya rina court se
réfugier
une attaque de l'aviation russe nous
dira-t-elle plus tard
marina ne cède ni à la colère ni à la
frustration
à chaque de recherche mais il garde une
pensée pour sa fille de 7 ans évacuée
aux pays bas avec des amis car son père
est réquisitionnée comme réserviste de
l'armée ici à sync rails at radio canada
montréal